when you hear mamble you think of
football my goal we started was to be
relevant in Houston area and we've done
that we're the mecca of this town we're
the hub of this town or a rural small
town outside of Houston and that's
pretty special to have built that in a
pretty short time I really wanted
someday for little kids to be playing in
the yard in mamble Texas wanting to be a
maverick and you'll see all these ball
boys running through the tunnel with us
and it's like a calf scramble at a rodeo
everybody says they're coaching to
change lives
well we truly are we work really really
hard at building the person has playing
very unselfish to help this team be
successful the life lesson and the
things that we teach here are the
ultimate prize whatever you do in life
you're trying to win you're preaching to
a kids you know be unselfish you know
make good grades do all these different
things you're showing the blueprint to
be successful but you're not successful
it's kind of hard for that kid that want
to buy into what you're selling in that
regard weddings are really important
football's gonna come and go X's and O's
are great you know we're really good at
football okay big whoop once footballs
done then what do you have hopefully
they've learned some things in our
program that teaches them about life and
more importantly it's our job to help
them get their school paid for if kids
want to play college at the next level
there's a place for almost everybody and
this teams built on trust you know so we
demand that they have self-control and
you can control your attitude to the
situation really am passionate about the
game of football I love everything about
I love the physical news I think it
makes you tougher for the game alive
you